happy 50 Years of Hip Hop y'all know who
the first baller with bars was but let's
see who can cook and who shacked in a
fool Braun it's on you yo who wased
count all of my rings forget lyrics on
the gr y'all mouth off on the screen
most points I took the crown off of
Kareem mua they pray on the downfall of
the king it's the slim Reaper Live In
the Flesh my game speak for your no
subtitles a text booking build my dogs
we Rough Riders and X this rotation
change make the sunrise in the west they
said I was too small when I entered the
league now I'm the Gog more than just
hitting some threes ankle breaking
spacing in the quickest release not even
magic had this many tricks up his sleep
who made the heat coaching shift H bu
born to kill like an endorsement deal
did it Just for kicks step to me better
be careful what you wish that's the last
thing before you die if you want Jimmy
bucket list me like 50 in the game wi
the MVP drop 50 in the game Max contract
on I never leave the city there's $200
million worth the game even Gilly would
say I'm the king of Philly to him man
you're not the king of Philly I run the
East now more like Fresh Prince watching
Butler clean house you carry the heat
Butler pull up and shoot clean jumper D
up stick the buckets like a street
drummer if Harden leaves the process is
cursed so prone to injury a coach really
a dock and a nurse y talking spicy you
got some nerve making call outs with no
rings do not disturb look another super
team with a cast the fresh names trying
to avenge your losses oh that's your in
game your super teams took the league
five steps backwards Clos the book of
King James that's my next chapter you
left us for the Nets I want another ring
to hold the throne while Kevin lost in
New York I stayed home alone hey yo cut
the beat go to work big fella let me
talk directly to Steph you had a 3-1
lead nevertheless I conquered the
largest deficit yet took food off his
plate and sent compliments to the chef I
never left the bay is the only place for
my trophy case all my rings in a golden
state that means bronze lower rank I set
records change the game Trend I got the
will to win the more effort the less
pressure he cing back with Avengers I
got a vendetta best center Crown me King
the best
[Applause]
ever wait is this what you guys do in
the
offseason
losers